[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
liar
liar pants on fire
Fox News decides it is better for them
to pay Dominion
800 million dollars
than a special Master to reveal the
truth
about Rupert Murdoch and every single
one of the Liars at Fox and I will
refrain from calling it news is the one
disappointment that I have in this
settlement is that the judge in the
settlement did not force Fox to take
news off their moniker their name
because they're not news we have all
known that we all know it
we all know they're [__] viewers know
it for crying out loud folks the whole
point is the LIE is the cruelty that's
a feature of Fox News is the lies and
the cruelty it's the whole point you
think their viewers are watching that
[__] going oh this is this is all the
truth it's the whole truth nothing about
the truth no they want to be lied to
they know they need to be lied to
this is important for their worldview to
stand in in the modern times of 2023.
they have no other choice but to accept
lies
and to try to Pretzel themselves
into absolute
absolute [__] boneheads
to believe
the things that fox and its anchors say
and do on a daily basis
so am I disappointed in the fox
settlement not really I mean a lot of
people are like oh Dominion should have
took him all the way
should have went and spiked the ball in
in the end zone well here's the thing
Dominion is a for-profit
company
they make voting machines that's their
profit now in this country our
expectation of Corporations
isn't of the government it's not
to do something for the citizenry or for
their country we should not expect
corporations
to do our work
now the reason why Fox News settled
is in the final hour I mean they were
trying for weeks to come to a number
apparently but Fox News throughout this
number of almost 800 million dollars
in the final minutes before a special
Master would be appointed and this
special master was going to have
sweeping power
in deposition and subpoena
I mean he the special Master whoever
would have been appointed would have
been able to say look Rupert you're
getting in a room with me and I'm
getting to the bottom of this [__] did
you defame them
and they did that's why they paid 800
million dollars
Fox News didn't pay 800 million dollars
because they knew they weren't guilty
Fox News paid 800 million dollars
because they knew they would [__]
lose
especially with a special master that
could get to the bottom of the
defamation and the lies and the knowing
of the lies and that's the point that's
the point that's the point of the
defamation now the best part about the
whole thing here's what I'm excited
about here's what I'm oh my God again
the professional rake steppers out there
of the Republican party and manga are
just my delicious this morning
oh we're goodness now we can sue CNN and
MSNBC go for it [__] go for it do it
sue the New York Times The Washington
Post suing you dumb [__] sue
them do it
do it
I dare you
you [__] first First Amendment
freedom of speech Bros I was like yeah
this this lawsuit is to try to prevent
Fox News from having their freedom of
speech listen
when I tell you again and again and
again and again open your [__] ears
you moglodytes the first amendment has
nothing to do with no consequences that
is not what the First Amendment says
Dominion is not the government
a civil lawsuit against defamation isn't
the government you stupid bastards
you do not get to say whatever you want
without consequence that is not a thing
in the First Amendment says it nowhere
in there that there are no consequences
for your speech
they just can't gag you of your First
Amendment right the government is they
and this is why I say now folks this is
going to be an unpopular opinion here
with my audience and the left
I don't think Fox News should be should
should be broken up or should be stopped
I don't believe that at all that's not
what I believe I believe that we have to
get louder we have to do a better job in
the liberal media and I'm not talking
about [__] CNN CBS ABC or MSNBC those
that is not liberal [__] media folks
that's not liberal media that's the
Press I'm talking about biased liberal
media pro-democracy propaganda like here
I I am the liberal media you
[__] come after me do it
that's right I spew pro-democracy
propaganda here on the Tony Michaels
podcast try to twist those words
but the liberal media needs to do a
better job now and forever
it is time we step up our game and that
is what I am here for every single day
of the week
to pressure not the right wing sure I go
after the right wing every day fascism
is on our front doorstep and we must do
something about it
and what we do is get better and better
and better at the media conveying our
message
forming the narrative framing what our
society should be as a liberal democracy
that's right liberal democracy
running from the word stop being scared
of strength liberalism is strength
and we can protect our institutions we
can protect all the great amendments
that all the megalodites all two of them
are three of them that they even know
about
and we can do it without having to
sacrifice
the ideas
of liberalism we can do it
and again I'm not talking about [__]
CNN or NBC or MSNBC
they're not the liberal media folks
they're the Press
there is a difference between biased
media like here that's that's right I'm
biased to the truth
oh oh people are gonna cut this up one
day a.m April 19th Wednesday is a good
it's a good a block rant to cut up
to accuse me of something uh moglodytes
make sure you make notes of that later
on in the future as this show grows and
you get more and more terrified of this
show and its audience because folks
that's really the truth here that's the
truth [__] Fox News they can do it and
say what they want
just like I should be able to say and do
what I want here on my show
and I'm telling you as we get bigger as
our microphones get louder because I
just have one microphone just one but
you have thousands of microphones and I
can't wait for the day that I get to say
you have millions of microphones we're
not there yet we're getting close we're
good I I really think
I really think we're gonna have millions
of views very soon I I just I just don't
think
that
um the liberal media again
not the press the actual liberal media
is not doing a good enough job to reach
people in a way that people will watch
and listen on a daily basis and continue
to engage in their democracy to save it
but I believe in you the audience here
the greatest audience in the world and
that's the most important thing folks
that's the most important thing why do
you think these bigots travel over to
Fox News to listen to that [__] lying
dribble they go over there because
that's what they want to hear
without being told they're stupid
Antiquated ideas of bigotry
rather it be against the lgbtq community
whether it be against liberalism and
democracy itself
people of color women disadvantaged
groups in this country whoever it may be
immigrants I mean the list goes on and
on of their bigotry over at Fox News
as they continue to do that
and they placate to an audience that has
to have that narrative pumped into their
brains 24 7 to keep them focused to keep
them on the side of bigotry we will get
louder we will get prouder we will have
more and more people joining our
Coalition you can damn well better bet
that and I don't just mean on this show
I mean in liberal media in general
I'm here to set the bar that's what I'm
here to do is to raise the bar for
liberal media get off your ashes and
start yelling and screaming stop talking
about polls stop talking about data no
one gives a [__] about your Academia
they don't give a [__] they really don't
they real really don't average Americans
don't give a good God damn
that they have that they have to recite
Academia to back up their arguments
listen making sure you don't go broke
because of a medical bill it's not a
hard argument to make making sure that
children start school at three instead
of five so people don't have to pay for
two extra years of daycare that's not a
hard argument to make making sure that
children have food at school so they
don't go hungry not a hard argument all
right making sure that people in this
country when they do seek higher
education rather through a tech school
or a college or a university don't have
to be saddled with debt for the rest of
their lives yeah I don't think that's a
hard argument to make making sure that
people get decent [__] wages they can
they can afford the inflation in the
economy yeah not not that hard of an
argument to make it really isn't folks
what do you think all that is that's
liberalism
it's Freedom of Choice it's opportunity
go look up the [__] word I'm
serious go look it up go look it up and
recite
the definition of liberalism
and then go look at conservatism
and figure out which one you want
I'm telling you folks I'm telling you
our allies are there they don't even
know there are allies of the
pro-democracy liberal Coalition they
don't even know it yet
they will
I guaran damn T it we pound this drum
and pound this drum and pound this drum
for decades yes it's gonna take a long
time but we can fundamentally transform
the framing and the narrative in this
country just like the right wing has and
convince these people that we're not
even a democracy Jesus Christ I showed
you a a video a clip of Lauren bobert
the other day going we're not a
democracy world world Republic we're a
constitutional republic listen then you
don't even know what democracy is if you
don't understand what a constitutional
republic is does or how it works you
[__] boneheads
they're lying to these people but these
people want to be lied to because the
reason why they don't like democracy and
the reason why they actually don't like
freedom of speech the reason why they're
super [__] pissed that Fox News is
now paying for its freedom of speech
because it knew it lied on air and it
continued to do it
to shape to shape a violent insurrection
in the coming months of their lies the
big lie in particular and to stand back
and for them to say well we were just
reporting on them what the president of
the United States was saying
you knew what he was saying he was
texting you you dumb sons of [__] him
and his team and his allies that were
spreading the lies that's what Fox News
didn't want
Fox News didn't want the entire country
to know the truth that yes they
coordinated with Trump and his allies
and the special master was going to get
to the heart of it
I really truly think that there if if
this would have went any further Fox
News would have been exposed that yes
they were part of the insurrection
they were instrumental in convincing
Americans that they should go to the
Capitol that Joe Baden would stay on the
election and liberals and Democrats were
stealing our government
and they were going to make you
communist
transgender people by making you drink
Bud Light and eat woke M M's I don't
know I don't know you you try to figure
this [__] delusional [__] out
all I'm trying to say folks is [__] Fox
News who gives a [__] let them pay 800
million dollars it's not going to phase
them at all and this isn't over smart
manic still has their lawsuit Dominion
still has lawsuits against Mike Lindell
Sydney Powell and others that were
involved in the big lie and perpetuating
the big lie and the defamation of
Dominion
but Fox News is not out of the woods yet
and smart manic hopefully will make them
pay just as much or more
but it's time for us to get loud
it's enough of this [__] that we have to
stand back and and wait
as we see and hear what Fox News is
gonna tell Their audience
[__] them
it's time that we get loud and proud now
right now not yesterday not last week
not next month not next year during the
election no right now
you must use your microphone
you must and you must use your ears and
you got to use your feet
it is important whatever you can do to
engage in your democracy now is what you
should be doing
that is what will kill Fox News
Fox News the only reason why Fox News
went balls deep into the big lie is
because their audience was gonna walk
away from them if they didn't
they would have went to Newsmax or oan
where they were willy-nilly lying over
there which by the way Newsmax and
Newsmax and oan are not out of the woods
with Dominion either
this is not over the big lie defamation
lawsuits are not over
and if you think 800 million dollars
isn't going to kill Fox News but if you
think Newsmax and oan aren't [__]
their pants this morning of 800 million
dollars
800 million dollars would crush you in
or Newsmax absolutely obliterate them
they would not exist
they just wouldn't
Rupert Murdoch is is a very shrewd
businessman
and the only reason why Fox News
survives is because Fox News has
agreements with cable and satellite
companies to get a percentage of their
subscriptions
it rather people watch Fox News or not
if you subscribe to cable or or DirecTV
you're given Fox News your money
and Rupert doesn't give a [__] if you
watch Fox News Newsmax annoying are not
the same they do not have those
contracts frankly they're not even on a
lot of those platforms now
because they got too [__] greedy they
wanted more money they wanted the deal
that Fox News got and DirecTV these
cable companies were not willing to
handle it hand it out to them
so it's coming folks the Reckoning is
coming for the right wing media what are
you gonna do about it what are we gonna
do about it I'm gonna keep yelling and
screaming every single day as the
Independent Media
that's right Independent Media right
here at the Tony Michaels podcast who
the hell is going to shut me up
you think there's a you think there is
an entity or a person in this world that
will get me to stop talking into this
microphone I highly doubt it
good luck to you now you can go over to
my patreon maybe I should up this now
that I'm
now that I'm casting threats out into
the into the media Universe maybe I
should change this you can go to my
patreon you can actually pay me 50 000 a
month and I will not talk what what do
you think that number should be do you
think that number should be 800 million
now that now that Fox News has settled
for 800 million do you think that would
be a good I don't know what the number
is to be quite honest
that I would accept on a month and this
is per month okay not just fifty
thousand dollars all together this is
per month if someone wanted to pay me
fifty thousand dollars a month over on
my patreon and you can go look at it and
go to patreon.com see Tony Michaels and
you can see that tier
that tier exists on my patreon you can
pay me fifty thousand dollars a month
and I'll shut up at this point and I'd
have to agree to it because that's part
of the
patreon
but what should that number be what
should it be I'm asking the audience
what should that number be over there on
patreon to get me to shut up hmm
again folks
someone says I better never sell out I
won't I again I'm not tied I'm not tied
to any entity there's no one telling me
what I can and can't say
and the minute the minute that someone
tries to tell me I can or can't say
something and I have to shut up guess
where I'm going not there you better
well damn guarantee that
that's for damn sure
my my work is is for democracy
you can say all you want about Sorrows
or even even that I'm I broadcast for
Midas Touch Facebook page you can say
all the shits you want
but the fact remains
nothing nothing holds power of this
microphone you can damn well better bet
that
not like Fox News
Fox News
did not want to lose their audience
had to lie had to lie and that's the
difference
is Fox News built an audience that
needed to be lied to that has to be lied
to they need the lines they feed off the
lies their entire existence
depends on the lies
we rely on the truth here
the real raw simple truth
we don't we don't have to placate
again this morning I'm sure a lot of the
audience and most liberals out there are
so upset they're pissed off that Fox
News wasn't taken to the mat in
courtroom by no minion I'm not mad about
it I'm not mad about it it's Dominion's
absolute right to take 800 million
dollars in this defamation lawsuit
frankly I'm glad Dominion took 800
million dollars now they got the money
to go after oan and Newsmax listen if
you don't understand media understand
that the problem that Fox News is is
only in existence because of the real
serial Liars of oan and Newsmax I don't
know if you watch I mean we play Clips
here all the time of Steve bannon's
stupid ass show on rsbn
of Charlie Kirk's [__] garbage on
that Network Newsmax oan these places
are vile heaps of manga trash
and fox has to compete with their lies
to Keep Their audience
because eventually their subscription
cash is gonna run out
and one of these days Fox News won't
have the ability to survive an 800
million dollar defamation lawsuit like
they did this week
foreign
their lesson folks
they're not gonna learn their lesson
this isn't like out because Fox News put
out a statement of course they did not
apologize to Their audience of the
American people they would never
apologize they're [__] their their
[__] Nazis they're [__] fascists
of course they're not going to apologize
for the fascism they love it
I mean the cruelty is the point
but they did admit that they made
falsehoods lies [__] lies
so I ask you to not give two shits about
this Dominion
settlement that Dominion took 800
million bucks but listen to me when I
say this 800 million dollars is gonna
pay for a [__] little lawsuits against a
lot of other [__]
that defame Dominion okay it's gonna
it's gonna afford a lot of [__] a lot
of [__] lawsuits
suggest sent back and let Maga eat rake
because they are professional face
Planters it's a sport for them
we must focus in on 2024 not 2022 or the
lies or excuse me 2020 the lies of 2020.
we must focus in on what is most
important Jesus Christ yesterday we
spent the entire show Absolutely driving
wedges between Ron DeSantis and Donald
Trump and we will continue to do that we
showed Chris Christie driving wedges oh
Chris Christie there's talk Chris
Christie's going to run for president
good do it
do it the more [__] idiots we get in
this Republican primary race the more
wedges we can drive in them
it's gonna be glorious folks I'm gonna
show you the way every single day every
single weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific here
on the Tony Michaels podcast you can
watch it on YouTube live or on a replay
just go follow the Tony Michaels podcast
on YouTube make sure to hit the Bell
notifications also follow us on Twitter
as long as it still exists at Tony
Michaels pod download every this is the
most important thing
you know what you could do for me more
than anything over the next couple
months is download the [__] out of this
show I know you watch it live here on
YouTube or on a replay and do me a favor
go download it over on Apple Spotify or
Google you know what you can do this is
really cool download the episode take
the first 30 minutes where I'm yelling
and screaming speed it up to like two
it'll only take you like 15 minutes to
get through it and it's funny as [__] to
listen to me in twice the speed I'm dead
serious it's hilarious it's [__]
funny I've listened to it I went over
and made sure that my speed you can
still be
someone understood that's one unique
thing I don't have a lot of dead mic
time you guys notice that for some
reason I can talk for two straight hours
and not stop it's a it's kind of a
talent
so go listen on all on all the
directories Apple Spotify Google
download it and listen to the first 30
minutes in twice the speed also if you
have a Facebook account
join us over on Facebook at the Tony
Michaels and listen if you want to give
money to the show without having to give
money if you have an Amazon Prime
account
you can do that that's right if you are
an Amazon Prime subscriber you can give
money to the show and it not cost you a
single nickel because what happens is
you get one free subscription on Twitch
with your Amazon Prime account so if you
go over on Twitch and you link your
Prime account to your Twitch account you
can give us that one free subscription
every month and you have to renew it
every month it has to be redone every
month but every month we get two or
three dollars I don't know exactly how
much it is by the time they take the fee
they they take their cut you know what I
mean
but it's free money from Amazon that you
can give us so if you want to support
the show monetarily
without having to give money if you have
an Amazon Prime account it's a perfect
way to do it just go link your Amazon
Prime account to your Twitch account
and if you don't know how to do it just
Google it or go to YouTube and say how
do I link my Prime account to my Twitch
account it'll show you it's really easy
and then you renew it every single month
it's also hat week here at the Tony
Michaels podcast you see the red [__] em
hat we are going to make Red Hats
wearable again that's right Red Hats
wearable again this week is hat week you
can use the promo code hat week 10
that's
h-a-t-w-e-e-k-10 hat week one zero hat
week 10 at the Tony michaels.com just
hit the hat store link and go use the
code hat week 10 hey Loki I know you
wanted beanies we had a patreon party on
Sunday I think I'm gonna have the
beanies ready this afternoon I'm gonna
try to get it this afternoon might be
today or tomorrow I'm working on getting
beanies in the hat store and I will make
I will make it to where the the new
um 10 off hat week code works because
that's what you get when you use the
code hat week 10 you get 10 off your
entire hat order it's on hats only at
the hat store that's hat week 10. go to
hats.detonymichaels.com or go to the
Tony michaels.com and grab your [__] em
hat if you get a red one let's make Red
Hats wearable again everyone stick
around we'll be right back right after
this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
well it was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we got plenty of Slam jams skull
near run out Natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag not the lived love and blue one
in your absence I discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
yours Tammy
[Music]
[__] um
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome
welcome back
Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
every single weekend Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
on YouTube Twitter and twitch
speaking of twitch we had a comment over
there it says hey twitchers
thought I'd come by renew and say hi
thank you Cloud e live cloudy live I
think
cloudy live went over and said hi to all
those folks in the twitch chat and
renewed their subscription so thank you
very much for going over there and
renewing your subscription uh to the
Tony Michaels podcast on Twitch
we've got a lot of lively chats here
I want to give you an idea so we have a
chat that happens on YouTube on our main
Channel
right that's where the that's where the
majority of the champ family lives then
we we broadcast to the up wires Channel
if you want to subscribe to the up wires
Channel they have a lot of other
creators we broadcast over there
and I put some of my shorts over there
too go to the upwire.com that's the
upwire.com you can find their YouTube or
just search
the up wire on YouTube and you'll find
it
also we broadcast from my Facebook page
and the Midas touch Facebook page so we
have two chats going on over on Facebook
we also have the twitch page
but you've seen cloudy live saying came
over to say hi to the twitchers
and renew their subscription now there
is a chat on Twitter and a lot of people
comment but I can't see
I don't know why it's Elon probably it
really is I can't see those chants so if
you're on Twitter and you're watching
that's cool and all right
but come on over to YouTube or or twitch
or Facebook if you still got Facebook
most people on Twitter don't have
Facebook though it's either like one or
the other you ever notice that some kind
of [__] thing about it like I don't
want [__] Facebook or I don't want
Twitter I don't know just people's
preference
I mean I I have an Instagram too and if
you want to follow all me all across
social media just go to the Tony
michaels.com just scroll down you'll
find all the social media links there
I'm even unmasked on I don't even know
what it is I mean I know what it is but
I don't know what to do with it to be
quite honest people keep telling me to
join
um spoutable and a couple others I'm
like Jesus [__] Christ are you
kidding me do you have any idea how many
social media platforms that I post on
it's just it's ridiculous it's
absolutely crazy what what someone needs
to do and it may exist I don't know [__]
I don't know we could Escape Sanchez
what someone needs to do is create like
one social media hub thing that you go
there and you just like post one thing
and it just post on all the [__] [__]
it gets ridiculous like this morning I
posted my my clip on World War III the
Easter message that the Cheeto dust
kiwin honor sent out
I posted the clip on that I sent it on
patreon over the weekend but I finally
posted it today
the reason why is because it takes me
forever to just post One Clip because I
gotta go to this one posted you gotta
wait for it to load and then you go to
this one you post it's a pain in the ass
it really is I mean a lot of people like
oh you're bitching about social media
yeah I don't I don't like all these
platforms I don't necessarily want to
post on all these platforms I mean I
would say up until Elon really about
four months ago five months ago after he
bought it and just destroyed it Twitter
was my favorite
but YouTube you honestly YouTube's
becoming one of the more popular ones
that I go to and watch shorts on there
and of course the the majority of the
audience that listens to the show is
over there so I can talk to you in the
community page I don't know I like that
one Facebook it's all right Instagram I
still don't fully understand it I don't
know I don't get it I mean I watched
some of the videos over there and the
reels but I don't know I don't I don't
get it as much Tic Tac I'm not that
excited I mean all this started on Tick
Tock I used to make videos on Tic Tac
that's how the show kind of started and
I'm not you know what I don't have the
time to sit by the time I get through
YouTube videos by the time I get through
Instagram and then I've scrolled through
Twitter I ain't got enough time to go
over to tick tock are you kidding me
Jesus Christ how much time do you do you
expect people to have so look at this
[__]
it's getting ridiculous again that's why
I say we need like one [__] for
people who post on social media to post
to all of them like all at once
just
oh by the way speaking of twitchers
does anyone here I am creating more work
for myself can you post like post on
Twitch or is it just the streaming
aspect or can you post like Community
notes and [__] I don't know someone can
tell me over on Twitch there's there's a
lot of folks that watch on Twitch that
are Avid twitchers I'm not an avid
twitcher not really I mean I just
I I broadcast over there
and we we try to build the audience over
there because I I think there's a big
huge audience that could benefit
from the pro-democracy propaganda here
that's right I called it pro-democracy
propaganda that'll really piss him off
you know what I mean like that's kind of
my intention sometimes is just to piss
him off
you know like when they call me the
rushland ball the left oh that's kind of
piss that pisses people off and it was
last month no it was February didn't he
die in February I don't know when did
when did what month did Rush Limbaugh
take a dirt nap in was it February I
think it is anyways in February when
Rush Limbaugh like the three year
anniversary or two-year anniversary is
death
um it came up that I might be the
Russian ball the left
and I talk about it here on the show and
people were tweeting it out
and it pissed liberals off they're like
oh my God
oh my wrestling ball was so bad he was
so of course he was bad and horrible
he was selling lies he was making it to
where we had the slow walk to fascism
the left can do the exact same thing in
the opposite direction folks
you're act you're acting like The Human
Condition is different because someone
prefers right-wing politics over
left-wing politics it's the same man
The Human Condition is the same
in general now you have people who are
kind of you know lunatics
I mean sociopaths [__] like that but you
know that that's the French
that's not the majority of people the
majority of people in this country are
pretty much this in the same boat of
Human Condition right that's why it's so
ridiculous to think that a simple
message can't be sold with the truth
that it can only be sold with lines
that's all a bunch of [__]
you can sell a simple good message that
frames a narrative for Liberal democracy
with propaganda that's right I said the
bad word
Gabe Sanchez I don't think he likes that
word I don't know maybe he does maybe he
doesn't I like the word welcome I don't
care I mean grab him by the propaganda
that's right that's what I say [__] him
you know
I mean that's a nice hat you got too I
you know oh thank you you told the story
Matt your hand you've been wearing them
a lot lately yeah but um you know it's I
have other hats I can wear as well you
know this one I just feel like it just
it's [__] hat week man it's [__]
hat week I know so maybe tomorrow you uh
did I send you more than just the red
one or just the red one no just I sent
you the yeah see I said so it's when
Gabe first
um came on the show he was a guest he
wasn't the co-host or producer no no and
he would he has these videos back then
and run now too I mean he still exists
but he doesn't do anymore but he had a
red hat and he would tape like a a piece
of paper that would say um
but there was it was sad yeah originally
they were make America great again like
piece of paper that I would tape on and
then later I was like well why am I
giving more attention to this dumbass
brand so then I made hats that said uh
I'm a 100 or a bona fide conservative oh
yeah that's a good one it says I'm a him
for uh White uh I'm a sin for domestic
terrorists yeah and uh huge huge
hypocrite
these are the things that the Hat said
yeah yeah that were just I would still
just put on duct tape and I would tape
it on right and you had a red hat that
you used to tape it on yeah so I was
like I'll send him a a red hat so he's
got another in case the other one wears
out in the videos yeah yeah right so you
have a red [__] em hat so yeah I have a
red [__] hat and uh that's the only
color I have there's there's well I need
to fix that then you got gray you got
black you got blue you got two I need I
need to finish them well we got we got
pink ones over there and by the way um
we are gonna I I think tomorrow or today
or tomorrow we'll get the beanies up
we'll have [__] beanies and we'll put
that into the yeah the spring they've
now added more hats finally yeah well
I'm I've been embroidered to it I think
I'm gonna do it on the hat store though
oh okay because they got different
choices they got better choices for the
beanies it seems like they're a little
better yeah and that's the reason why I
have the hat store and the other one
right in the merch store the reason why
is because the hat store the the the
provider that does the hats they have a
lot more options for hats than they do
over on just the regular merch store so
man that's why they do hats over there
that's how it goes what are you gonna do
I mean you know it's like if you've got
a hat store why would you why would you
mix up hats with clothing you know it's
like not it's like well there is some
there is some shirts over there on the
hat store she can get shirts over on the
hand store and and you can get like a
thanks thanks Brandon mug a lot of
people like that mug it's got the
remember the thanks Brandon videos yeah
so it's got the it's got the sunglasses
and the aviators yeah yeah I mean those
are those are classes
I was taking their let's go Brandon and
mocking them yeah [__] them yeah [__]
them I like the uh I like the mugs that
are the magic mugs the one ones that
they're usually either I think they're
typically like all black mugs but
um when a hot liquid is put into the mug
then that's like in this stuff kind of
like a text message shows up or things
like and I think uh give it to someone
as a gift and it's just a black mug and
then they pour their coffee and then
right or like to kick your teeth in
right yeah yeah exactly yeah you're like
so wait so so could it be a gag gift
that's like someone you love or someone
you hate you're like well yeah so it
could be somebody hate like it could be
hey you [__] Nazi I'm gonna kick your
teeth in right right or or uh you know
great day to punch a Nazi that would you
know that would be so funny because if
you gave that mug to like an ally they
were like yeah I love this mug but if
you gave it to someone who's like oh man
I don't like this I'm not a Nazi like
dude if you're butthurt over mug saying
punching Nazi you're probably a Nazi
right or they might smash the mug and be
like
the uh
well I tried to look those up but none
of these like none of these stories they
don't offer that yeah see and that
that's the tough part about merch like
because for us to provide merch it's got
to be very
um effective and easy right right right
because it's very hard for us to go like
print a bunch of merch and then have it
sent and buy it and then and then do the
process of shipping I've done that and
that's a lot of work it's a lot of work
and there's no guarantee you could
invest in all that stuff and then nobody
well I guess I'll be wearing this shirt
for the rest of my life
so you have stacks of shirts yeah I got
you know small ones mediums large ones
like I'm just like fluctuating my body
size and my weight so that I can adjust
for so do you like tie it up in the
front yeah you know I get a little like
get your message
you know people like what's what's going
on there and I'm like you gotta buy to
find out you know right right but those
mugs would be cool they would be I had
one in college I had one in college that
was uh it said Jesus saves yeah and then
when you got it uh when you when you put
uh hot liquid in it all of a sudden he
his beard was gone and it said Jesus
shaves
nice nice Jesus shaved so the other one
that everyone wants is gum whistles
right oh because
does our store offer it I'm trying to
find the [__] whistles so the the
hidden message what'd you call the
hidden message mugs the magic mugs yeah
they like the magic motorcycle that's
the way that I call I don't know if
that's the name of it so so those mugs
and the whistles are two things that we
would have to go outside right the
providers for or just contact them to
request them but I can't find a whistle
there's other things but not a not a
whistle but I I like the idea of [__]
whistles I'm not gonna lie
I think I think like if we did [__]
whistles and somehow we've we funded it
because we don't have any [__] money
um
literally we don't have any money right
now but if but if we if we can find the
funding then we could like send the
[__] whistles to a lot of these
protests right you know what I mean
The Branding of of a whistle to have
[__] him on it is very appropriate yeah
it feels like it just goes right in line
with it listen the [__] brand is I
and again I kind of stumbled into it
accidentally right because I feel like
[__] them is like the perfect protest
right it's the perfect protest like [__]
them and it doesn't matter what it is
[__] them [__] em [__] them [__] them
you know if you don't like it [__] them
but the thing is is like when you The
Branding is great but everyone's like
and you know this people have called me
personally like hey man you could be
nationally syndicated this show could be
on AM radio if Tony would just stop
saying the word [__] and I'm like well
then the show would fail are you kidding
me what the [__] would I be without the
word I guess we could call him
fam so so I would just have to start
saying uh instead of yeah like you up
the mother you [__]
which could be its own thing it's like
when uh when you're like man that's not
yeah yeah right so so on the patreon
party and I know you were a little late
wow okay so so I I did my rendition of
rinder scilla have you ever heard of
rinderzilla I don't know if I have so
it's Cinderella right the story but it's
render so it's kind of the same thing
you're talking about once upon a time in
a corn fun tree yeah it's a beautiful
Burl and the Beautiful Burl's name was
rendered sounds like the worst song to
ever try to perform for the sake of
you're going to pick up the words it
wasn't song It's a story I tell oh it's
a story of the story yeah it's a story
okay I told the story now Wayne Flemings
does a uh a great version he's a
comedian from Canada he's one of Jim
Carrey's idols and uh I I think Wayne
died many years ago but he did a
rendition of rinderzilla and he and he
did a he did a curse word version and of
course there's no curse words in it
because it's like Foo
you know what I mean yeah so turning
around it's great it's great maybe we
could do that and get on AM radio if I
just talk like that I doubt I could
sustain though like when I'm in my rants
yeah you know and I don't know somebody
says
what was that that show called the good
yeah it's a good place and she would be
like holy holy
um
fork and shirt balls yeah like my my
chemistry teacher in high school used to
say
uh chips and giggles
yeah shut the front door yeah and he
would say what was the other one he
would say it's chips and giggles and um
chips and Giggles you should make a
t-shirts chips and Giggles
not wait wait I got a new nickname folks
okay I got a new nickname for Gabe
Sanchez
chips and Giggles over here wow look at
this look at this [__] juice
look at chips and Giggles over here he's
all oh man there was another one
I'll try to think of it but there was
another one he had that was just like
that
where he was like oh yeah we'll just
blah blah and then he would say it and
everyone's like oh God like it was like
oh [__] dad joke over here
get the fork out of here with that shirt
God I can't remember get the fork out of
here with that shirt I don't maybe I
could I don't know maybe I could do it
but I don't I don't think what if you
called it what if you like fukum Fook
fukum Fook yeah what the [__] out of
here with that shirt I don't know
I don't think it would work I don't
think people I mean it's not as like it
doesn't have the same right right I mean
I'm pretty good at cursing too like yeah
yeah I mean I I want to admit like I say
a lot of F words a lot but
but sometimes like in my shorts
um because I don't edit the shorts now
we get someone else that doesn't yeah
like when I get them I'm counting the f
word how many F words are in it I'm like
damn I almost got to five in 60 seconds
like I almost got to 5 in 60 seconds
that was almost five [__] now I think
when I used to do tick tocks and I you
know that a long time ago long time ago
in The Tick Tock Universe they were only
60 seconds that's it that's right as
long videos you could post you can put
anything past 60 seconds
and I think my record was like 13 [__]
in 60 seconds oh wow in a rant that's
that's pretty impressive good that's
funny uncensored all [__] just right
[__] unfiltered the pure Tony right
[__] well you know it's funny some
people would comment and they're like
can he get any more F words so I'd count
them and I'm like okay I'm gonna try to
get more tomorrow and at the end you're
like [__] yeah well see that's where
[__] them came from it's because at the
end of each walking rant that I would do
on Tick Tock I would say at the end [__]
them that's what I would say and then I
started to do these other videos like on
my front porch as opposed to the walking
rant and I didn't say [__] them they
were just it's a different kind of video
people were mad they were like what the
[__] where where is where the [__] is
the [__] in this [__] video
ridiculous you're not saying [__] them
at the end I'm very highly disappointed
so I was like oh my God so so then but
again I I kind of stumbled Into The
Branding right right but I like them you
know that's how it goes man sometimes it
is it happens it happens that's how it
is so you know what we should do uh
because I know I know we want to get
into this fox story yeah there's a
couple other stories we want to get into
but let's let's do a little bit of shoot
the [__] here I think this is a good
opportunity so if anyone has any
questions for me or shits and giggles
here then um our chips and games
I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm trying to like
as we're talking I'm trying to think
back into my brain which one that was
the Deep recesses of my brain trying to
find in that file because like what did
my what did he also say there was
another one too but I'll keep thinking
about it okay good well if you got any
questions for me or chips or Giggles
here give me a get a mess get a message
get a message in on the uh on the chat
and and we'll go for it
um okay here's one let's see uh hey Tony
how much do you think the Kraken is
going to get sued for well I think she's
already being sued for a certain amount
by Dominion yeah Sydney Powell because
that's the one thing I was talking about
in the first 30 minutes is like this
isn't over with Dominion Dominion's got
several lawsuits they're just warming up
man right well it's unfortunate I will
say this my only I'm like yeah almost
800 million is is nice but
I mean considering the fact that it's
like I think their their annual revenue
is like 17 18 million or something like
that so this is like Way Beyond that uh
I am kind of like Ugh disheartened that
I wanted to see that [__] I wanted to
see the dirty laundry but that's that's
the thing that you have to know though
is that it was worth 800 million dollars
for Fox News not to be under a special
Master right that was that that was the
turning point in the negotiation I just
want them to leak the transcripts
somebody [__] leaked the transcripts
that they already had because we've seen
some stuff I want the rest of that stuff
and that's what Dominion kind of said is
like hey we got what we got but it's not
over yet because we are still suing
because they're still going to see
Newsmax and oan oh yeah and I cannot I
can't answer I can't tell you how much
Newsmax and Owen are [__] their
pants after they watch Fox
give them 800 million bucks oh yeah I
mean they and and Mike Lindell had to
[__] his drawers yesterday when [__]
Fox paid them eight because
listen as much as the left is
disappointed with this settlement Maga
is terrified they are [__] terrified
of this and the reason why is because
this proves what we've been saying all
along that fox [__] lied to you they
fed you full of [__] they convinced the
Sheep the manga sheep out there to bleed
this line perpetuate this line and it
ain't just Fox it was Mike Lindell it
was Sydney Powell was Rudy Giuliani it
was this scheme down in Georgia the
scheme in Arizona which was almost the
exact same thing it's Georgia it just it
just they don't have a prosecutor there
that has the [__] balls on them like
Fanny Wells even though you know Fannie
Wells is a woman but she got some
serious [__] nuts on it you want to
know how much
how much is Cindy pounds yeah yeah it's
the same as Mike Lindell so they're both
they're they are both individually
getting sued for 1.3 billion and I found
that you're being excited for 1.6 right
right right and I didn't I didn't know
how I thought she was less than that I
knew Michael and Devil's 1.3 but the
fact that they're both 1.3 alien with a
B right yeah with a B right so even if
they have to settle
for I mean they're not gonna well I
don't know can't canned over 800 million
bucks neither can Mike Lindell which I
mean in all actuality I would love for
them to have to hand over 800 million
dollars I would also love to figure out
where Michael and Dell is getting this
[__] money from right because we know
that he's not making the sales in all of
these brick and mortar stores anymore
and they're all like supposedly online
sales for my pillow so what I want to
know is where is the money coming from
that's allowing him to fund all of these
legal services and like you know counter
lawsuits and this is wonderful and and
to keep Frank speech.com up and running
you know and also because the other
people he's got he's got speech that I
know I can't believe that's what it's
called Welcome to Frank speech.com I
cannot believe that's what it's called
Uh but he's also I mean like Roger
Stone's got the [__] Stone zone or
whatever the [__] it's called Uh I don't
know like get in the zone with Roger
Stone
um he's got that and then also we should
have like stoned Zone day for me
just get stoned on Me on the air what
are they gonna do to us what the [__]
are they gonna do I would be curious is
it stoned on anything
well I mean why not okay what what do
you want to get stoned on well I just
you know I won't I I don't wanna I don't
wanna
come on yeah Jesus Christ you you chips
we'll just say we'll just say it's an
organic substance oh okay I got you well
I mean I would I I can't listen I I've
part partaken uh in the past few weeks
in in Edibles yeah and I'm not I'm not
I'm not a big I got honey in my fridge
I'm really I'm not a big huge fan I'd
much rather my favorite drug is alcohol
I hate to disappoint you but that's my
favorite drug but here's the thing is
that I can't smoke
at least I don't feel like I can smoke
marijuana because I'm I'm a cigarette
I'm that former [__]
[__] you I'm a former I'm a former
cigarette smoker oh oh okay I can see
how that would be so I quit I quit about
10 years ago right right I I went to a
wedding
um this is about four or five years ago
and they had a cigar bar there and I I
grabbed a cigar and I I clipped the end
of it smoked it and I went and I took a
you know a few Puffs off the scar I'm
like whoa nope like that way too much
way too much that you were able to stop
yourself while that was happening I
actually gave it to someone else because
I was like nope nope can't do that
because I I mean as much as much as I I
don't like smoking because I don't want
to smell like cigarettes it's [__]
expensive it's gross yeah um my wife
[__] hates it so that's another
reason not to to smoke when someone you
know I mean hey that you're trying that
you're trying to get in bed with doesn't
like when you're smelling I mean yeah
isn't happy ain't I we had a we had a
sign on our front door when I was
growing up and it said
uh if mama ain't happy ain't nobody
happy right and that's the truth it is
that's the truth well I mean we were
talking about this the other night and
and someone said that my wife is always
right I said yeah I know she's always
right I don't always listen to her
I mean because I'm a [__] guy I'm a
bonehead but yeah she's pretty much
always right it's very rare that she
isn't it's very rare that I listen
because I'm an idiot I'm a man or you
say something she's like yeah I said
that like three days ago and you're like
no I thought of this and she goes no you
didn't no well the other thing too that
men do because we're [__] boneheads
is they'll tell us something and like 10
minutes later it's like what's your
plans for today like you [__] I
just we just do not listen to what I
said we just had the conversation yes I
did not yes I did not listen see that's
that's what I always say it's always
affirmative right you don't want to be
negative yeah yes I did not listen I was
not listening to what you said yes yes
were you listening yes I was not
listening to what you said see that's
how you get away with it
um back to the question here one two
three one point three is what they're
being sued for but right but I think I
think the more important important point
is not how much they're being sued for
or is that Dominion has shown that
they're not going to set away at a court
right right so that's the other thing
they take it up to the finish right take
it up to the one yard line the [__]
jury was sitting there waiting right and
and the judge had to come and say hey
jury sorry but they reached the
settlement yeah so like I understand
that people wanted and I I get your
sentiment that they wanted to see all
the information come out in court but I
believe that Mike Lindell Sydney pound
news max o a n may not be able to settle
with Dominion no um and the reason why
is because they can't reach this 800
million dollar bar and really with Fox
setting that bar with Dominion Dominion
can sit there and say [__] you if you
can't pay what they paid then because
your lies your lies are 800 million
dollars in value of damage to us that's
what your lives made money that's what
you got subscribers off of the lies that
you told about our company and it's
worth 800 million or because we got the
proof because Fox 800 million yeah so I
understand that people's frustration but
really honestly and I get their
frustration about Fox News more Newsmax
or oan because Fox News is is the
channel That most these [__] people
who are delusional watch but Gabe they
want to be delusional so but also we
have to remember that this was a 1.6
billion dollar lawsuit and smartmatic
has uh 2.7 billion dollars
so that's a again
2.7 billion dollars now we've already
set the Benchmark for roughly a little
bit less than half right less than 50 is
what they settled for for what the
actual lawsuit was was taking them to
court for now you've got a lawsuit that
is
almost three right or sorry almost yeah
almost three billion but a 2.7 billion
uh so now it's a question of like are
they going to settle for over a billion
right like we know if you look at the
financials for Fox News what I read
yesterday was Fox News had
4.1 billion dollars in cash and cash
equivalents so that that's all the money
they had in terms of what they could
right now that they could liquidate or
have liquid to pay out
um to anyone who is like hey look you
owe this much money they're like oh [__]
okay let's get on a payment plan
and I think that's one of the main
reasons because it's like
they wear they very well could have gone
to court and Fox News said
or the jury said okay you guys owe 1.6
or you owe more than 1.6 right and then
there's obviously the issue there where
then they can appeal it and they may get
a lesser amount later on whatever what
it might be and it's clear that Fox News
like [__] it we don't want to risk this
at all because we've already been caught
multiple times like even recently they
were caught withholding information from
the court and they're like oops my bad
didn't mean to do that well that's what
the gender is going to appoint the
special Master because it's like whoa
whoa you were you were making sure you
were hiding stuff from Dominion you
can't do that we're gonna appoint a
special master and this fact really LED
them in the end and the whole idea
they're like well it wasn't it wasn't
like it wasn't newsworthy or it wasn't
uh it wasn't
uh yeah I guess it's just like worthy or
important enough to show and it's like
well you thought it wasn't but now you
definitely made it that way you know
where if you're like if you didn't think
it was a big deal you wouldn't have hit
it but now that you hit it you made it
an even bigger deal
so it's clear that they're like [__] man
it's it's crazy in terms of like what
the
what what they're going to be charged
with so I'm curious to see how
smartmatic plays out because that's the
one that's gonna be an even larger
amount and again they've already set the
bar 787 and a half million dollars to
cover up and and pay for the lies that
they told
2020 2021 and parts of 2022.
so we got some more questions here for
the shoot the [__]
um Steve says I think he's directed you
Gabe you got honey in the fridge
we'll take her out
I think he I think he means weed Honey
Steve I think is what he's yeah yeah
yeah
we did it is it yeah yeah yeah so it's
pretty does it does it taste any
different or
um more of the smell if anything like it
smells like you could smell the weed but
when you when you just like you know
take a little Spoonful and you put in
your in your tea then you don't what the
Yeah in here I mean you could just you
could eat it straight up if you want you
could put it on a peanut butter banana
sandwich if you want peanut butter
what in the [__] are you doing man I'm
trying to enjoy Jesus I'm trying to
enjoy myself here but yes you can easily
just be like wear eyes for him where I
was from and I know it's close to where
used from is we don't put peanut butter
our bananas on our peanut butter
sandwiches we put jelly on it we put
jelly what are you talking about dude
here's a quick pull for the audience all
right all right peanut butter you can
okay you can have bananas or jelly do do
the poll no no seriously going to
YouTube all right all right and do the
poll on the YouTube chat you can do a
poll on the chat go do a poll on the
YouTube chat and everyone if you want to
get in on the bowl go over to the Tony
Michaels channel on the YouTube chat
don't forget to subscribe when you're in
the peanut butter
do you do you prefer bananas or jelly
this is the dumb question anyways this
is really stupid because it exists I
have sandwiches you can put dog [__] on
your peanut butter sandwiches doesn't
mean you should
put jelly on your peanut butter
sandwiches so okay hold on everyone
knows this even uncrustable knows this
duh man I haven't had a crossbows in a
long time you like ingressibles
I mean they're they're good for what you
like Uncrustables on weed
do you put your honey do you put the
honey on Uncrustables okay why you're
why you're doing that pull everyone uh
participate in that pool I'm gonna go
the next um question here yeah
um
um well it's not a question is James is
posing a question to the ladies I'm
sticking with hunka hunka Latin love uh
what do you think ladies so he doesn't
apparently James does not like
apparently James does not like the gifs
and Giggles I don't I think it's kind of
cute chips and Giggles we should get him
to make a t-shirt
um with his face on it okay um Cynthia
actually has a question here she says
what about the No Labels [__] I I
think you're doing the No Labels
campaign that's all [__] horseshit
that's a right that's a right-wing
campaign to try to draw back people uh
into the Republican party that are
walking away because of the crazies like
Trump and Kerry Lake and my guess is
that it's far right Wingers uh doing
this to try to get him to walk back into
the Republican party because they're off
their [__] rockers man did you see
that 61. see 61 DC Republicans endorsed
Donald Trump yesterday do you know how
many endorsed Rhonda Santos
two oh really wow
2 to 61. that's pretty who was the who
is the one in Texas that uh yeah he was
he was like talking good about Rhonda
Santos and then he came out and endorsed
yeah and he was like with that being
said and then he went first yeah see if
you can find that video we'll play that
video if you can find that
um and the polls out there by the way
the poll's out there and the question
was
did you sandwich do you like more I said
Which sandwich do you like more peanut
butter and jelly peanut banana I don't
know how do you want a phrase but right
now it's 64 peanut butter and jelly 36
percent peanut butter I know what the
numbers are gonna be made listen this is
why I don't stand there's a shot there's
a chance this is why we do not talk
about data and polls on this show is
because I don't need some stupid ass
poll to tell me what the hell I can use
my taste buds with peanut butter and
jelly and peanut butter and banana okay
I got taste buds I know what it tastes
like I know which one's better you
apparently don't but you know that's how
it goes I'm just saying my I like I love
peanut butter and jelly
uh but I also really like I love bananas
bananas are great apples are great you
give me a [__] uh Granny Smith apple
or a honey crisp or a pink lady you
throw that on you slice it up the honey
put that on toast you know a piece of
bread with a sandwich boom call it a day
no I love it no more I love it that's
great chips and Giggles from now on
um Melanie asked um question Tony and
Gabe do you play any instruments I don't
actually play in I mean I can pretend to
play an instrument yeah but um I sing
that's about it as a kid I used to play
the sax for like a couple years and then
I got a an electric little you know uh
Casio piano with the goal I was like you
know what I'm gonna learn
how to play the piano again right
because I played it as a kid and I
haven't I'm always like oh you know
there's always something else I can do
you know so what can you play any songs
like Mary had a little Lambie I could
play the simple stuff like Chopsticks or
Mary had a little lambs the [__] that
everyone's just like the basic party
favors you know someone's not gonna
think some Beethoven I'm like yeah I'll
do you one better I'll do one better you
ever heard this it's called Chopsticks
you know
fantastic now thanks for the question
Melody and oh I guess the closest thing
would be like
like uh uh drumming you know oh yeah
well I don't know I [__] on a
harmonica I can make a harmonica sound
like I'm doing something I don't know
what I'm actually doing but I can make
it sound like it but I sing I sing
everyone a lot of people know now that I
can sing
we did the karaoke on the patreon Gabe
didn't like it because he doesn't like
country music that's what it is what's
the poet I'll tell you in a second we're
totally ignoring the great Massachusetts
culinary Heritage of the fluffer Nutter
oh that's the that's peanut butter and
uh peanut butter and uh and marshmallow
oh well hey you know what you know what
other what other National Institution
and it's where I come from by the Lake
of the Ozarks um it's a marshmallow
Pepsi it was invented [__] is that
marshmallow Pepsi yeah you know the the
marshmallow that they put in like um
like shakes and [__] and ice cream
they put marshmallow in shakes yeah it's
like a it's like a marshmallow [__] that
it's like you know you squeeze it in
there it's not marshmallows it's like
marshmallow I've never had a shake with
marshmallow like yeah like well yeah
yeah I mean where do I get that on ice
cream or but what the [__] that's what
I'm I'm trying to tell you where you get
it God damn it she come to Central
Missouri there's a town near the Lake of
the Ozarks car called Eldon and then
Eldon e-l-d-o-n Eldon and there is a
there is there is a a hot dog stand
there it's called the creamy Drive-In
it's a it's it looks like a barn I'm not
[__] you it's shaped like a barn and
it's really run down I mean like I'm
sure from the outside you're like how
many Health codes are being violated
yeah this thing but they got the best
[__] chili dogs there ever like the
best they make a Frito pie oh my God and
then the famous thing is marshmallow
Pepsi but I don't like to like [__]
that's way too sweet I never really
liked the marshmallow Betsy but if you
like really sweet stuff marshmallow
Pepsi and that's where it was invented
right there marshmallow Pepsi so the the
pull right now uh has peanut butter and
banana at 67 percent
peanut butter and jelly peanut butter
and Jelly's at 67 and peanut butter
bananas at 32. of course it is yep 68 32
now this is out there yeah that's right
200 245 five people who have voted come
on folks vote vote vote in the poll even
if you're watching this did you know a
lot of people watch this on their TV
a lot of people watch a shitload of
people watch our show on on the TV oh I
guess I never looked at the analytics
Yeah man they a [__] ton of people so
like what's the breakdown on the
computer on the TV on the phone I I
can't remember exactly the last time I
looked at it but not just not just like
looking at the numbers because I don't
think it's always telling the whole
truth because it depends on if it
depends on what app they're using
because if they're using their phone to
cast it to the TV then it's gonna do a
phone
when we did the patreon party because I
was gonna do Zoom people were worried
about not being able to watch it on
their TV because everyone wanted to
watch the patreon party on their TV in
their living room I can screen right
there were several people that had
people come over to their house
to watch the patreon party on TV so they
cast and I have several people that have
sent me that said they watch it on their
TV program I'm sitting on my TV
that's right is it right see they they
want and sometimes they'll cast it I
think they cast it from twitch or
they'll cast it from from Facebook
because you can use like uh AirPlay
um
to cast almost anything to your TV if
you got it set up yeah see that Nancy
Hayes says peanut butter and maple syrup
oh that's I don't know if I would do
that but that sounds interesting
definitely sounds interesting
Pepsi collab anyway sorry well okay
what's the next one Pepsi collab yeah
peeps did a marshmallow Pepsi [__] them
people they were like any credit card I
didn't get any credit they partnered
with the dentist the Dental Association
they're like you guys have this and we
gave a little Kickback when they come
into the office I'm telling you man if
you eat a marshmallow Pepsi from the
creamy again if you like sweet stuff but
if you're not that much on sweet stuff
it will [__] knock your socks off
you're gonna be like oh my God
it's like I mean Pepsi is sweet enough
right because Pepsi is actually sweeter
than Coke that's what makes Pepsi do the
taste that's why they win the taste test
because that first ship is sweeter but
when you dump a shitload of marshmallow
like liquid marshmallow into it
it's just liquid sugar that's sad
um here's a here's a question about
politics instead of [__] what we're
doing
um Tony did you see the fetterman video
no can Gabe can you oh yeah I think I
know what they're talking about so
fetterman got out of a car and showed up
at the Capitol and waved to people and
uh this was today or yesterday
this was like two days ago because I
because I know Mitch McConnell came back
um from yeah nobody had [__] to say
about Mitch McConnell but then when I
mean other than man why I I was rooting
for the steps in that one because then
he fall down some steps
I don't know he's I was waiting for this
what do you want from me what do you
want Jared is Jared as as representative
Jared Moskowitz said who you know
represents Parkland he's like they're
[__] idolizing a slip and fall victim
which is true that being Mitch McConnell
81 they're like 81 year old slip and
fall victim Mitch McConnell
um right uh well the other the other
thing the other Senator that people are
talking about this morning that has not
returned to the Senate and it's and it's
a big Hadoop today
um is Feinstein from California your
state of California
Jack Schumer Chuck Schumer yesterday
tried to have a resolution on the floor
but the Republicans blocked it
um to temporarily replace her on the
Judiciary Committee because the one
thing that's happening
is the one thing that the Senate can
actually act on at this point to put
into place which is judicial nominations
from Joe Biden now Joe Biden has um
nominated more judicial appointments
than any other president I think before
him
um and our Senate that we have now uh up
until the point where uh Dianne
Feinstein has been out for the shingles
uh has actually uh got through those
nominations and those appointments so
that those those judges can be seated on
courts
um now here's here's my view of it is
that Dianne Feinstein she's a duly
elected Senator right the people
California voted for her and there's not
a goddamn thing you can do about that
she can stay in that seat for as long as
she wants now I I do think Democrats in
the Senate need to make it very clear
that Republicans are terrified that that
Democrats are trying to seat
uh Federal bench justices and that I
think it needs to be the narrative of
here and again I I want to politicize
everything right I want to politicize
everything that's the whole point is we
got to win elections right that's how
you win as you politicize [__]
um so we should politicize this now some
people think Feinstein should go I'm not
against it you know I I think I think um
I think I'll tell you from someone from
California dude she's got to go man
right but here's here's the thing that
I'll tell you that that I think Dianne
Feinstein and her her staff really need
to consider and the people around her
really need to consider do you want to
be known as the person who are holding
up judicial nominations as there's
federal judges that are trying to strip
women of their rights the Supreme Court
with Clarence Thomas and it seems like
um others on the Supreme Court Mike Lee
this morning is defending Harlan Hitler
oh my God what a pile of [__] [__]
Mike Lee is defending Harlan Hitler are
you kidding me because yeah I don't know
if you know this but Mike Lee was a a a
a clerk for Alito the the other person
who's probably no telling how much money
he's received from Harlan Hitler I mean
we can only assume that Harlem Hitler
isn't buying just one Supreme Court
Justice he's trying to buy them all yeah
what did he say that's defamation what
who yeah Mike Lee he's claiming that
yeah
and Clarence Thomas's defamation hey hey
Mike hey Mike I'll give you defamation
and I'll raise you 10 [__]
Harlan Hitler is trying to buy his way
into making sure his idea of fascism is
instituted in our country one
[__] [__] him that is not how a
republic our democracy works you stupid
bastard you should know this but Mike
Lee is a Bashas so he doesn't know it um
so the fetterman video play the second
video first from Grant yeah play that
one and then hit the third clip after
that and then we'll go to the first one
okay so what is this first one this is
him this is the C-SPAN footage yeah do I
need to play the audio uh yeah he says a
line he's like okay okay I didn't know
if it was just like footage of him
it's not going to be very loud anyways
he's in his uh his hoodie as normal his
sneakers his shorts
good to be back this is what he said he
said good to be back yep and then boom
okay so a lot of Republicans yesterday
were like oh my God could you believe
the outfit he's wearing can you believe
he showed up in a hoodie and shorts and
gym shoes wait wait wait they're mad
that John fetterman showed up like have
they do they know who John Federman is
well their argument's gonna say they're
like well when you show up to the senate
or Capitol Hill
listen well you're I know where you're
going with this because I know the video
of your show but here's the thing here's
and I want to give commentary on this
before I before I show the video that I
know you're gonna show of some other
Senators doing the exact same thing
here's the thing who do you think
[__] beat Dr Oz the dude in the
hoodie man it's the dude in the hoodie
who had a stroke who was recovering from
a stroke who beat who beat the Trump
back candidate Dr Oz who is a
carpetbagger from New Jersey
why the [__] are you surprised that
fetterman's showing up in the same exact
hoodie he whipped his ass in why are you
surprised by this this should not be a
[__] some frankly I think the rules
should be changed where John fetterman
can go on the senate floor in this
hoodie I think this idea that you have
to dress up and be a certain way I think
that's the reason why people are pissed
off in this country in the first place
so [__] them okay so we're gonna play
this the third one here is this the one
of the other Senators showing up I don't
I couldn't find a video but I did find a
photo so this is the photo yeah okay sad
so this is the photo
um and you know you'll probably
recognize this piece of scum in the
front here I don't know if you know this
guy
yeah Cancun Cruise he really does look
like Eddie Munster in this one I mean I
think he's just just uh Eddie Munster
who did not age well but Ted Cruz this
is so there's a video uh and I and I
can't find it but basically what happens
is
the Senate is having a vote
and then and and he showed up in gym
shorts and they're like hey what are you
doing he's like oh I just came back from
a game of basketball with the whoever
right wait Ted Cruz can play basketball
no because if you look at here I'm fine
I'll play this video I would I would
love I would love
to watch Ted Cruz you talking about when
he's drinking the ball between his legs
you can watch him play basketball
against Jimmy Kimmel
what there's a yeah are you [__]
kidding me this exists all right so
basically the backstory to that is at
one point a few years ago
uh Jimmy Kimmel kept calling Ted Cruz
the human blob or whatever he looked
like the fish that was like
yeah cause Ted Cruz is a so they they do
this thing and then they challenge each
other to a basketball game they they
both I'll say this they both did not
play great okay I wouldn't expect Jimmy
Kimmel to be a good basketball player
but they played and it was like for a
charity or whatever
um and they played against each other
because this challenge had been done
anyway so that's that right and we've
seen the video where Ted Cruz tries to
bounce of basketball and he can't quite
Bounce It Fast isn't that like in that
like um b-roll footage that he shot for
like his campaigns and [__] yeah I think
it might have been but they have to
release the whole thing right right but
then uh Jimmy Kimmel used that footage
let me see if I can find it use that
footage against Ted Cruz to be like oh
looks like you're really working working
well there let's see but you know in all
seriousness that a lot of senators are
going to walk around the halls of the
Capitol in gym clothes because there's
the [__] gym there that they use like
there's gyms there's bath houses there's
showers they have cafeterias I mean they
have libraries I mean these people work
and live in that building yeah I mean
essentially and and they should they
should they should [__] have to I
mean especially when you you know when
you're writing legislation and you have
to vote on it like there are some you
know people are filibustering like you
you're there all day all [__] hey
you've got set up and you got a little
bed and yeah how long ago was this video
this one here
it's it's a long time because this is a
crazy shitty beard yeah
there's a barber shop in the capital too
why Ted Cruz doesn't have them trim that
shitty beard instead look at this this
I want to say 2018. yeah 2018 because
Jimmy Kimmel has a video that says he
was setting up a few ground rules and I
don't want to play that video because
we're gonna get dinged for it but yeah
because it is Jimmy Kimmel but I tell
you what Jimmy the 2018 June 2018.
this is when this is okay let's let's
watch it this is not very long and we'll
just play it on Loop up
oh he's really hitting a sack there I
think I don't know if he was going for
the sack or what but I don't know that's
gotta I mean if you had if you had a
decent SEC that would probably hurt I
mean and here's the thing the reason
that that basketball game all started
was be ah damn it hold on don't that
wasn't a link
I'm gonna go to this fetterman video
that you sent that first one
um and then we'll come back to the
Cancun Cruise
um here is uh here's the fetterman video
this is the one and I haven't watched
this yet is this before or after this is
after so I think you made it to
yesterday oh okay so this is after he
showed up and people gave him [__] yeah
hey everybody it's me Senator John
Federman and I just want you to know
that I'm back and I'm feeling great 100
percent
and you know during my time during the
hospital the fringy fringes really came
up with the conspiracy that I have a
body double and I just want you to know
that is just crazy that's not true and I
hate no dude John what event happened
this afternoon yeah
why not [__] goof on these idiots
listen John fetterman is one of the best
of Leaning into the to the [__] that
they throw at him like he did so well at
this during the campaign and they should
keep doing it he's he's great at leaning
into the [__] that they throw in him
what's this one what's this one here oh
so this is what started this whole Jimmy
Kimmel Ted Cruz Feud where he was like
Ted Cruz I can't really tell which one's
which to be quite yeah I know I mean
this is one of those moments where like
corporate wants you to tell the
difference between these photos Can you
spot the difference right I can't really
I don't know that I got it I it's just
it's tough isn't it they looked uh it's
talking about
body doubles for fetterman right this
really feels like there's two Ted Cruzes
to be quite honest with you I'm just
saying or two Ted Cruz or two of these
blobfish things I don't know I don't
know that's crazy anyway so that's the
update on uh fetterman okay yeah so so
there's there's the veteran video um for
everyone thanks thanks for the the the
question there their MO
um do we have any more questions Jesus
Christ we're almost at the bottom of
this how the [__] does two hours go by
so goddamn fast man it just it flies by
it's not even close it's not even close
uh let's uh wait hold on Kalyn says she
found who could make the [__]
whistles for imprint has a police
whistle product you can add to your
brand name too but the question is
do you do you have to buy those whistles
ahead of time yeah and then ship them
yeah
we have to have money but I listen me me
and Gabe me and Gabe um this is what we
do for a living and we appreciate our
patreon sport all the sport you guys
give when you buy [__] em hats or merch
yeah yeah um and that's how that's how
we keep going here but we we're not paid
by Soros and Soros definitely isn't
going to send this [__] whistle money
so I mean
I'll just have to last night I had to go
yesterday was my birthday and I had to
go and I got my birthday but you gotta
look out you gotta look out for those
free meals man you know those free meals
like so I don't know oh okay you're in
L.A there's a there's a sushi spot that
people some people in La might know
Sugarfish and if you don't know this on
your birthday you get a free Omakase
Meal which is I it's just become a
tradition between myself and a bunch of
people that I know and we just go there
everywhere you got some free sushi free
sushi and then and then uh like I've
never I haven't been to Denny's in years
but I think Denny's does something for
your birthday and
um Jenny's ice cream you get a free ice
cream cone on your birthday so I had
sushi and I want ice cream so it's like
you know
everybody give birthday
um wishes to chips and Giggles here
chips and Giggles Giggles in the chair
he already hates it I know he does
inside he's like you [__] why
did I say that so to Tony's Point yes we
are not paid by Sorrows we are paid by
your support patreon or merch or
whatever it might be so right or if you
if you um if you link your Amazon Prime
account to Twitch we get a few bucks so
we get that
um some people just tip Us in the tip
jar you can go to the Tony michaels.com
and do that so that that all that helps
out that all helps out
um also if you want to be my sugar daddy
or yeah George Soros whatever listening
whatever start sending those [__]
chicks dude all I'm saying is if you've
got cash or just spend
do it yeah right make it out the chips
and Giggles Incorporated
now I'm kind of curious if that exists
she just Giggles Incorporated make it
out to then oh man um let's see do we
have any good clips that we want to play
yeah well there are some there are some
good Clips coming out of a hearing right
now with Marjorie Taylor green go to
Ace's account
unless you want to do the fox stuff well
you know no I I mean I watched a really
good um clip of uh Margaret Taylor green
yesterday it's [__] insane where
she's standing outside she's like we I
reviewed 2 000 documents like
you don't even you couldn't read five
pages yeah I don't believe that that's
what she said okay so what what clip am
I looking here oh okay I see what was
that one I haven't watched that one with
my order
okay
um so this is Swan well and then I guess
he's showing Marjorie Taylor greens now
this is uh my orcas is being questioned
in a house in a house committee here so
let's let's take a listen to what's
going on inside there I'm disturbed
about a recent tweet from the former
president that says republicans in
Congress should defund the Department of
Justice and the FBI
I'm also concerned about people on this
committee and their own anti-police
rhetoric this is a defund the okay I
want to pause this for a second
um because this is a telegram it looks
like this is not a tweet yeah this is
telegram so um the funny part about her
little merch there defund the FBI don't
you have something that's similar to
that I do have a shirt that people can
buy in my store that's defund MTG okay
so if you if you go to the
tonymichaels.com you can go down to
Gabe's merch store and you can find that
there yeah you can also go to
store.imgapesanches.com and you can find
it there but yeah it's same same style
same same font uh I even I even
recreated the same little ad graphic
that she has and it's defund mgg that's
hilarious I don't have a hat but I've
got a shirt I figure that's good enough
it just it triggered it triggered that
my bro yeah yeah but this is a telegram
not a tweet and and swallow got it wrong
I mean I will call that out he meant
tweet but it's a post on fraud social
it's not actually well she yeah I mean
she also might have had I think she
might have had a tweet about it as well
right but here's here's yeah
yeah let's let's hear what swallow had
to say FBI campaign effort again
thousands of FBI agents who work hard
every day to take bad guys off the
streets in fact after the FBI raided
Mar-A-Lago someone armed the teeth went
to an FBI field office to try and kill
FBI agents I'm disturbed about we were
literally on we were on the show when
that dude showed up with a nail gun yeah
we were trying to figure out because we
were trying to figure out like where he
was at because it was there was
conflicting reports because we were live
on air and we were trying to figure out
they kept saying nail gun instead of gun
like yeah we're like what's going on
then it turns out he actually showed up
with a [__] nail gun to a local FBI
office thinking he would like find find
the people that were involved with uh
searching Mar-A-Lago what I also find
funny about this is like Cincinnati
though yeah it was in like the middle of
nowhere is in Ohio [__] the fun but the
funniest thing about it is how uh March
each other greens like defund the FBI
defund the FBI you know Donald Trump's
like defund the FBI and as soon as Ali
Alexander Ali Alexander or Ali Akbar
gets revealed as a groomer and a
pedophile or for sending an unsolicited
dick pics and all this stuff of course
because what are you trying to get when
are you trying to get an underage boy to
send him pictures
hey send me an employee an eggplant
emoji and they're like What's that and
he was like OMG you dick
so
they're all connected they knew they
knew what it was Ali they knew what it
was you got Milo yiannopoulos who is and
this is all a big inner War this is all
big enough and I'm gonna do a what was
that on it because it's just like
there's so much
to break down here because you've got
Miley Annapolis who is a known Pro
pedophile fam
uh but he also has a thing called the
vault which is uh videos voicemails
photos all the blackmail [__] that he
would need then he got Nick Fuentes who
is a uh he says he's a virgin he's a you
know [__] incel all that [__] well
that's what kind of sparked this thing
because Nick Fuentes used the sock
puppet account on Twitter to run a
Twitter spaces when was that was that
Saturday Friday was it Friday that was
Friday after the show yeah it was Friday
after the show
um and I think I sent it to you or no
you did you send it I sent it to you and
I was like yeah you're like holy [__]
Nick Fuentes is in this in this [__]
in this space talking about Marjorie
Taylor green Milo and Laura Loomer was
in there too yeah and she eventually
took the stage and this is what sparked
all this to come back because this kind
of happened about a month ago and
there's a few spats well there was a Oh
two so a week before that space happened
uh
Ollie Alexander was in a space with
Laura Loomer and they were doing The
Tick Tock of Marjorie Taylor green and
Milo so they're anti they're anti-milo
they're anti-marger Taylor green because
they thought that it was all this effort
to
um to weaken Donald Trump because they
set up the the the dinner with um
with Donald Trump Nick Kanye West right
and Margaret because Marjorie Taylor
green they claim marjor Taylor green was
kind of the uh the go-between right and
and and and and
um Nick Fuentes who is a [__] scumbag
Nazi Laura Loomer who loves Nick Fuentes
self-proclaimed islamophobe craziest
um these two people are now anti-margery
Taylor green now this is very important
folks that we make sure these wedges
stay where they are and we keep driving
them in because if Marjorie Taylor green
is trying to hurt Donald Trump or if it
appears that she's trying to hurt Donald
Trump we will make sure to get Carrie
Lee because his presidential running
mate which is what we want we want the
crazy of the crazy right out in front
for the American people to see how crazy
these [__] are Margaret Taylor green
has tried to Rebrand herself and I
believe that it's part of this Feud that
has caused her to reband herself we know
that Margaret Taylor green went to
uh aft pack which is America first
um CPAC in other words it's the Nazi
it's even if you can be more Nazi right
right and that's the one she showed up
to and she was like man it looks like
a bunch of canceled people in here or
whatever she said when Nick Fuentes was
talking about how he loved Putin and the
same in the same meeting that he he um
he was making Hitler jokes he's making
Nazi jokes yeah now then he talks about
all this in this space and I think
someone recorded it I don't know yeah
well here's the thing I found the
original it's he had it on his his uh
his normal stream he was doing it
simultaneous so I found that video I
found that footage and so I have
attractive I'm gonna again like it's
gonna take me uh at least another couple
days to figure it out but I I know that
I've for the people on patreon they were
I think uh Jay reached out was like oh
you should do the feud that's happening
between Laura Loomer and Martin Taylor
green and I was like yeah totally and
then in a week and a half this just like
blew up it exploded because in that
space a guy was like hey uh Ollie you
remember he's like oh yeah what's up man
blah blah blah he's like uh yeah so
turns out I've been talking to this guy
who was 15 at the time and he said that
you were sending dick pics and he's like
no no no no never did that never did
that so I have that space recorded wait
that's a lie too and so he's admitted it
so he denies it he denies it and
everyone's like oh what okay and he's
like oh this is all this is all you know
their company's an attack blah blah [__]
and then a week and a half goes by and
then these text messages come out the
story comes out and then he's like
this is so gay I mean he literally said
oh this is too gay I think is what he
said and he was like I've apologized
we're good right and then Nick Fuentes
was like Ali has said that he's gonna
bow out from the public spotlight
so it's good no need to attack him
anymore guys so there's like wow you
know what I remember I remember back a
couple months ago we played a a huge
rant from Ali Alexander I believe on
telegram or something yeah
it was someone's someone's uh it was
like it wasn't twitch but it was
right so so Ali is claiming that
Marjorie Taylor green has committed
several crimes obviously Ali is
admitting I mean when you're when you're
soliciting
um nude photos from a minor that scene
especially if it's uh from one state to
another that seems like a federal felony
to me I don't know and maybe just maybe
and maybe I'm off my rocker here but Ali
Alexander has went and been subpoenaed
and testified in front of several grand
juries right maybe he's traded his
immunity in some of those cases
and that's why it makes this whole thing
funny because Margaret Taylor green says
we gotta defund the FBI but as soon as
his story breaks about Ollie yeah she
goes we need the FBI to investigate whoa
whoa she likes the FBI when it's on her
side come on Gabe Sanchez
doubt then well here's here she is um
questioning my because I think this is
the homeland security yeah I mean this
is the same committee it's the same
hearing that swallows yeah I think it's
I think he's if you look at her she's in
the direction like I think when they're
around the room kind of thing like in
that like she's in that c pattern right
he's in the least important seat yeah
she's off to the side I think I think
the layout is swallow is at the front
there is off to the side she's on the
very end okay let's let's watch hoof
foot pedietti Marjorie green give her um
I'm sure this question is going to be
brilliant
rage complete outrage where China is
poisoning America's children poisoning
our teenagers poisoning our young people
how long are you going to let this go on
what congresswoman let me assure you
though she's talking about fentanyl
probably I I couldn't tell if she's
talking about fentanyl or she's talking
about
um Tick Tock or she's talking about
viruses or did you hear the new one the
new Magneto timeline the meat one yeah
yeah yeah yeah the magnetic meat that
that coin stick to coins aren't magnetic
you [__] idiots okay let's see what
my orcas is um response to this [__]
outrage theater is hiding the screen no
I reclaim my time you're a liar you are
letting this go on and the numbers well
actually I want you to take the words of
the speaker down
so in uh making a ruling on this uh it's
pretty clear that the rules State you
can't impugn someone's uh character uh
identifying or calling someone a liar is
unacceptable in this committee
because that guys that guy was a was a
green himself different spelling so
agree took down a green well and it's
the chairman and if you noticed it was
Benny Thompson the ranking member in
this committee who absolutely knows the
[__] rules of Congress in a committee
and knows that she can't do that yeah um
well she can again folks this is what I
keep telling you like about Foxy's and
[__] you can say this [__] if you want
out loud but that doesn't mean there's
not going to be consequences yeah yeah
and the consequence is that Marjorie
Taylor Greene gets stuffed in a trash
can here by Benny Thompson with the
rules and looks like a [__] fool now
she got her little Fox News moment that
the play on Tucker Carlson but they
won't play the part where her words are
stricken from the record let's continue
and I make the ruling that we strike
those words
foreign
just a point of order legitimate
question you're recognized thank you Mr
chairman did you move to take the words
down or to strike them Mr Thompson yeah
sorry I just stepped in
to take him down
so that's what we did yeah yeah my
understanding is if words are taken down
that means that the the member can no
longer speak in whatever the proceeding
is that those words were set
so this is this is Daniel Goldman and I
don't know if anyone knows but Daniel
Goldman is a very accomplished litigator
and lawyer and he knows a lot about law
and he knows a lot about how Congress
operates yeah so what is also the
semantics of you know if we're going to
say it's removed like this is you know
there's a
and I I mean I don't know it but I'm I'm
sure that
if he's asking the question it's because
he knows the specific language of how
they're using it to say like well if
this is true then this also is true so
if you're going to take him down then
they can't speak or if they're going to
be stricken or whatever it is I don't
know if they're synonymous
but he's like look man if you already
took that down then she can't open her
[__] mouth right well and that's and
that's what Daniel Goldman's doing here
is like hey if we're gonna follow the
rules let's follow the rules yeah Benny
Thompson set forward right um and you
that you agree to and you you gaveled so
let's keep listening
every point of personal inquiry that's
there's no such thing
okay so this is what again I I know I
know a lot of people are focused on
Marjory Taylor green right yeah and this
is what I've said a hundred times if I
say it in another million the reason why
Marjorie Taylor green Lauren bobert Matt
gatz or any [__] clowns like Jim
Jordan or these others or Jim Comer when
they're in Congress the reason why it
hurts the Republican party and again we
should encourage these people to remain
in Congress is because these people can
attract a serious staff yeah and and a
congressperson especially a
congressperson who doesn't know a lot of
rules and don't doesn't know Congress
very well relies on their staff to know
Congress and know the rules inside a
committee and know what you can and
can't say and what they do is to help
the congressperson through the process
of representing their constituents in
those committee meetings more than
anything
um there's another video I'd like to
show remind me
um about theater here in just a minute
okay just get in my mind yeah I know I
don't want to miss this
um but this is why it's so important
because not only is Daniel Goldman
attract a very uh highly skilled
professional staff but he's all he also
knows the rules himself because he's
worked in the halls of Congress before
he's actually sat as as an attorney
um for a committee right so he's been
the actual Council that's hired for the
committee to ask questions uh we watched
it during and Pete one of the
impeachment trials where he was asking
questions he was the attorney that the
committee had hired to ask questions to
litigate this idea
um so he knows the rules very well so he
he doesn't actually need a professional
staff he has one but he doesn't need one
but this is I I understand that people
don't like Marjorie Taylor green and
Lauren bobert and some of these others
being in Congress but look as long as
their districts are stupid enough to
elect these people who aren't actually
representing them and to continue to
[__] rake step and show that show the
Republican party for truly what it is
they're not serious [__] people
they're just not [__] serious
especially Maga these [__] fascists
aren't serious not only are they not
serious about what they're actually
doing it's all theater but they're
they're not serious about representing
their consensus they're not serious
about policy and because of that they
don't know how to govern
um so that's that's the through and
through here and that's what's showing
here because Marjorie Taylor green
doesn't even know that she can't do a
personal inquiry and and if she had a
decent staff that was standing behind
her they would give her away they would
know how she can combat this right
inside the Committee hearing they would
be whispering her what she needs to do
in that moment to combat Goldman and
Thompson because of the mistake she just
made but she doesn't she doesn't know
and she doesn't have a staff that knows
so watch but when we strike uh it does
terminate the time of the individual who
is speaking so uh the gentlelady is no
longer recognized
[Laughter]
the other thing is she has no clue that
that was gonna happen no clue and she
had no she probably also doesn't
understand what was just done right well
wait what and they're like shut up dude
shut up now what now what's gonna happen
is that she's gonna go out in front of
microphone and say she was silenced no
no no you broke the rules yeah Vinnie
Thompson called you on the rules and the
chairman the the chairman of your party
gaveled down to strike and remove to
take down so we'll see what happens here
so they cut her they cut her off here
but let's let's see if there's any more
to this because there's it's about
another minute left let's let's listen
uh the chair now recognizes Mr Ivy I
believe uh could I make a point of
inquiry Mr chairman you can so the the
ruling was that because she used the
word liar
um that was taken down which I agree
with yes but but accusing
a statement of fact is very similar to
the posters that uh Mr there's no
statement there's no statement of
[__] there's no there's no actual
basis for the statement oh damn did you
hear that the word [__] made it into
the microphone there Ivy's not having
any of this [__] he's like look man you
so now they're so they they got Marjorie
Taylor green silenced now they're going
after chairman green to make him go
steps further here which is very
important with the rules this is again
folks I know I know that it feels like
they're denigrating our great
institution of the House of
Representatives but listen to me when I
tell you this they are revealing who
they truly are and it is going to prove
to America that we not only can we not
trust them not to turn us into a fascist
State we can't even trust them with the
simple way of holding committee hearings
this is one of this is one of the the
main parts of the institution of the
House of Representatives to hold
committee hearings and they can't even
manage to do it I mean Jim Jordan is
[__] face planted on all these
[__] committees that were supposed to
reveal how Joe Biden was a criminal and
he should be the one in prison and all
this [__] none of them because they
don't know how to govern
um and and it was obvious when they
couldn't pick Kevin McCarthy a speaker
that that was going to be what was going
to happen let's continue here see what
else and transpires over the next 20
seconds we're not here to debate this
okay and the ruling was made by the
chair that these previous words were not
against the rules of
Clause one and Clause four of rules now
you see the man behind him the man
behind him is trying is trying to guide
the chairman through this because the
chairman doesn't even know how to handle
this with this yeah so let's see what so
let's see how he face plants here
because I'm sure he does at the very end
17. but to tell someone that they are a
liar is it's pretty clear in the rules
slander is clearly covered by the rule
[Laughter]
is clearly governed so
uh it's probably going to be uh more to
do about this uh clip so do you want to
see another clip of uh yes I do okay so
yes I do I I don't know what you're
gonna say but yes I do all right so uh
Goldman right who is just in that
meeting right he had his moment to to
shoot down Margie Taylor green he also
had another moment with representative
Luna
because they're they're like going back
to back hearings in this and so oh so
this is this is here just now yeah this
is like 20 minutes ago and this is um
so okay I've got here this is Aaron's
yeah yeah I've got it here so it's uh
Luna tried to interrupt Goldman is that
the one huh yeah okay it's a short clip
but yeah okay so it's the same it's the
same type of like
the no [__] given attitude this is not
the homeland security
um committee no I don't think so because
they're questioning someone else yeah
because the homeland security would have
been questioning my organs this would be
a different one um so here's this is
this is something because there's
another clip I don't know what the
actual the full one is but there's
another clip of uh
of uh Moskowitz because yeah yeah I'll
go back to that one I'll go back to it
uh Brad says from Facebook let them meet
rake I don't know who came up with that
in our chat but we we need that needs to
be darn moniker let them rake this this
is the thing that I'm telling you folks
it's gonna what what is Gonna Save Our
democracy is just let these people step
on rakes and keep eating them and keep
face blinding well let's let's listen to
the bass line here from balloon is it
Luma Luma Luna let's listen is that we
have what is clearly politicized
oversight trying to have a gotcha moment
against President Biden but my
colleagues on the other side do not
support
additional support for our veterans
they they did not support the pack act
well the gentleman yields for a question
I have 20 seconds
I will not yield let me just finish and
if I could have a little bit more time
Mr chairman you'll have plenty of time
to respond Miss Luna the the point I'm
trying they don't even they don't even
understand the time rules yeah and this
is the same stupid [__] when Lauren
bobert says I yield yeah no you [__]
stupid ass you yield back your time you
yield back there's more time to be had
you don't yield because it's not the end
oh my God so we have an answer it was
Rosebud she said she said it on the up
wire chat let them eat rake let it there
you go thank you boom said it I said
that thank you Rosebud thank you because
we're going to keep saying that and
Rosebud we're gonna give you all the
credit in the world here for let them
eat rake we shouldn't make a graphic or
something yeah we should something maybe
we make a shirt with the rake in it or
like yeah
rake it's fantastic we got the best
audience in the world yeah come up with
some of the funniest [__] [__] by the
way
um so thank you Rosebud okay because
we've been using it we're gonna keep
using it um here's um in the same
hearing this is my representative
moscowitz he's from Florida
um several weeks ago he absolutely
[__] he absolutely toured Marjorie
Taylor green apart up one side and down
the other uh on on and I I believe it
was after it was after it was after the
Nashville shooting and what she was
trying to say was because I did a whole
what was that on this that's what you
[__] demolished her
uh Moskowitz was talking about the AR-15
and he basically just put out this and
he set the bait and she fell for it and
it was
yeah she he said anyone want to respond
and she's like me and he's like
yeah the statement was murder in schools
is still murder if there was anyone he's
like I will yield to anyone in the room
who doesn't believe that murder in
schools
uh or who yeah who doesn't believe that
murder in schools is murder right so
the fact that anyone would disagree with
that is dumb but the fact that anyone
would would speak up and be like
actually she did that and he's like okay
go ahead yeah go right ahead and what it
was Marjorie Taylor green he's like yeah
step on your rake [__] yeah step on
your rake so who steps on the rake in
this one
I think it's just Republicans in general
he's talking about Afghanistan and
George uh President Bush okay so let's
let's watch Moskowitz here and do his
work in the Committee hearing
who says it's an important topic
you know we're a hundred plus days into
the next Congress
and this committee thought that before
we would talk about the Afghanistan
withdrawal they thought it was more
important to talk about Twitter
first
and not only did they think it was more
important than the Afghanistan
withdrawal they thought it was more
important to talk about
the hiring policies of the Biden
Administration
they also thought it was more important
to talk about
a laptop that was found at Radio Shack
before the Afghan withdrawal
you know they thought it was more
important to talk about the DC
government and public urination before
the Afghan withdrawal and so okay so so
there's another [__] clip and and I
think it's on the same hearing
and she stepped on a rake then too
because she's like now you supported
your public urination she's like no I
didn't yeah it was like didn't you vote
for this he's like nope never just like
like we they wanted to decriminalize it
but we didn't and the mayor didn't so we
changed it the problem is you won't vote
on it so it's not anything it's just out
there in The Ether because you won't do
your [__] job because a lot of people
don't understand this is that Congress
has the authority over D.C because DC is
not a state right DC doesn't have a
state government they don't have a state
Republicans do not want a statehood for
right and it makes and it makes sense
and again
it makes sense for DC to either be a
state or be part of a state it makes
[__] sense yeah it makes sense and
and if it's part of a state then maybe
Congress controls part of the city or
something and how it operates but and
all in all it should be part of a state
or a state itself for [__] sake it's
not [__] rocket science
um but Moskowitz is pointing out very
clearly The Tick Tock of this committee
and how how many rakes they've stepped
on they stepped on the Twitter file rate
they stepped they stepped on the Hunter
Box oh God he had uh uh Nancy mace right
she was like God bless Matt taibi and
the Twitter files yeah and then Matt
taivian and [__] Elon Musk can't even
agree and Elon Musk deletes all the
Twitter files because it's probably
going to put him in legal [__]
Jeopardy that's probably why he [__]
he deleted all of them but let's
continue let's see what Moscow is if he
has any more rake steps that he he
divines here I know this is a serious
topic
but just look at the hearings we've had
before this one
and so it's tough for us on this side of
the aisle to accept
that this isn't
a serious hearing this was a 20-year War
was started by President Bush
you remember President Bush I know many
of you have disowned him because he
disagrees with President Trump
but four presidents
20 years of good decisions 20 years of
bad decisions
you don't want to examine 20 years you
only want to examine like the last week
you know when marriages dissolve after
20 years and they get in front of a
judge
they don't just say you know everything
was great until the last week of
marriage
it's crazy
president Trump invited the Taliban
to Camp David around the anniversary of
9 11.
what why why why would Republicans want
to step on this rake now now here's the
thing here's what Moskowitz is trying to
point out here and it's on the record
he's saying look
this Afghanistan war was a serious
[__] thing and absolutely Congress
should make sure we evaluate the [__]
Afghanistan war so that we don't do that
stupid [__] again we do not want to do
that again we probably are as a country
in the future sometimes gonna have some
[__] stupid conflict that we should
not be involved in for a longer period
of time that we should be involved in it
and we don't want to do that again so we
should have value we should talk about
it we should go through step by step of
why what happened what happened but I
love how they went through all these
[__] stupid ass [__] so that he
can tee this up on a t and you notice
how Moskowitz is so good yeah at making
sure that he gets the messaging just
right Goldman's good at it she walwell's
good at it uh Hakeem Jeffries is one of
the best at it I mean you talk about
messaging and narrative and framing of a
certain issue is a master
King Jeffries is one like obviously all
of them come prepared like they don't
you know
Jeffries is someone where it's like dude
he could just [__] riff and let me
burn you down and piss on your ashes in
real time like and I'll tell you that
Jamie Raskin someone said Raskin yeah is
one of them Katie Porter's another one
um you know I I really I really hope
that California decides that Katie
Porter uh is in their camp for Senator
and the reason why is because I think
Katie Porter could uh could be Senator
until she's Dianne Feinstein's age I
really do and and if you're not if you
don't know what it means to have a
senator for almost their entire lifetime
uh to be in that seat for California
represent not just Californians but also
Americans in the way that Katie Porter
does uh for Liberal democracy and and
freedom and fairness equality diversity
man you're you're not you're not paying
attention I'm not saying there's not
other good candidates but I think Katie
Porter being one of the youngest
candidates in that in that group of
candidates
um and and her fire and her passion and
not only that her staff because her
staff will follow her to the Senate they
they will be a force to be reckoned with
on committees folks this is the
difference between because I ain't this
[__] when people say oh both sides
but get the [__] out you don't have any
idea what you're talking about when
you're talking about both sides if you
tell me that both sides are the same you
don't know [__] about our government you
don't know [__] about it you don't know
[__] about our Civics you don't know
[__] about how our elections work when
someone tells me when someone tells me
that oh Joe Biden should be primary
you're a dumb [__] you're just
not you you just don't know how our [__]
works and you're making [__] up you're
[__] totally making up false ass
narratives just like Fox News I love it
and I've got a lot of fans that are
Bernie Bros and love Bernie yeah and I
have some friends that are really real
they love Bernie and they would love to
see Bernie run but you're these are the
same people who argue that Joe Biden's
too old and they want Bernie Sanders to
run for president that is you people
just are uncoupled from reality
sometimes and let me tell you something
though the left needs to stop with these
delusions that of how [__] works right
the same way Feinstein because you said
earlier that you want Feinstein resigned
and you're not in support of it but the
reality is Feinstein does not have to do
[__] she doesn't have to she she can
destroy our late her Legacy here at the
very end of her end in the Senate
because she's not going to rerun and
Dianne Feinstein's not going to be
Sinners so she can destroy her entire
Legacy of her Senate to to at the very
end placate to this to this [__]
where a bunch of fascists are gonna stop
nominations from happening because they
want to fascist State I mean she's
really gonna just she's really gonna
bang up her Legacy and that's the
message I would be sending to her stamp
and her allies and the people who love
her is hey Weinstein needs to think
about her Legacy here more than anything
and and Gavin Newsom I think would do
the right thing and I think Gavin Newsom
would appoint someone that is in that
Democratic field that would have a
chance of being a really good senator
now I know know who Gavin Newsom would
would put in that in that interim spot
yeah and I'm not even sure the
California laws I don't know if they'd
have a special election or it's close
enough to the election where they would
just let that be I I'm not sure
um I'm sure there's some sort of law out
there that dictates that but here's the
thing is that we need more serious
politicians and yes we need serious
Republicans but they don't [__] exist
they just don't exist and the reason why
is because the minds of their party have
been rotten let's see if we can finish
Moskowitz here and I want to show you I
said political theater I wanna I wanna
see if I can find a video that I watched
the other day that I think is brilliant
let's watch this
like are there any questions about that
Trump released 5 000 prisoners many that
included terrorists 5 000 Taliban
prisoners many that included terrorists
um so this um again he's slamming they
gave him the opportunity to slam um this
other video and I forget his [__]
name and I saw it on Tick Tock see this
is why I don't like [__] Tick Tock
um he's a new Congressman he's from
there that's it that's it can you can
you uh is Jeff Jackson is it is that who
it is let me see yes I believe so
um uh Democratic party Jeff Jackson yeah
I mean he looks that's it that's him for
all intents and purposes
um you know he's confusing because he he
kind of confuses people like I do he
might look Republican he's from he is a
congressman from North Carolina's 14. so
you say he's from North Carolina he's a
white guy you know he kind of talks a
certain way so you might be um you know
he might be Republican but this video
here that he had
um is [__] brilliant and he makes oh
the one from two days ago yes and he
makes brilliant um he makes brilliant
videos on social media you should
definitely go watch him
um and you should follow him
um because he he's just talking truth to
power here in His Brilliant watch I'm
still brand new to Congress I've only
been there 100 days and I don't know if
I'm not supposed to say this out loud
but it's true and important and if you
don't know this you need to it's really
clear from working there for just a few
months that most of the really angry
voices in Congress are totally Faking It
these people who have built their brands
around being perpetually outraged it's
an act I've seen a bunch of examples
here's one I've been in committee
meetings that are open to the press and
committee meetings that are closed the
same people who act like maniacs during
the open meetings are suddenly calm and
rational during the closed ones why
because aren't any cameras in the closed
meetings so their incentives are
different what I've seen is that members
of Congress are surrounded by negative
incentives there are rewards for bad
behavior you know what the big one is
being able to reach you the big thing
that modern media and modern politicians
have earned is that if they can keep you
angry they'll hold your attention and
they both want your attention so if
you're a politician and you show certain
media Outlets that you can help them
Keep Their audience angry they'll give
you Their audience and because so many
politicians are willing to play that
game now they're in competition with
each other to see how fake angry they
can be so that's real bad but here's
something good what I love about this
about communicating with you directly is
that the incentives are different they
can be positive they can be about
speaking to you with respect and real
information and in a normal tone of
voice because if I can talk to you
directly I don't have to yell and if you
don't have to yell to be heard the whole
conversation changes so going forward
when you hear some enraged member of
Congress say something absurd your first
question shouldn't be how can they
possibly believe that it should be do we
think they actually do because they
probably don't and for those who want to
see politics look less like WWE I will
keep you posted it's almost like this
guy is listening when I say we are at
the intersection of WrestleMania in real
life doesn't feel like that now now you
would say that Tony he's talking about
you no I am not elected member of
Congress never would I baby nor would I
see KC in Congress and no matter how
many times people type it out and put it
in the comments I'm not going to be in
public office and the reason why is
because I am the West outraged machine
that's the whole point I should be the
one yelling and screaming I should be
the one yelling and screaming that you
should go use your ballot and you should
go use your your microphone and your
feet and your talents to engage in your
democracy to elect serious politicians
like Mr Jackson here and Moskowitz and
Goldman and swalwell people who are
serious about our country and how our
country works and that is the whole
point okay so we need to get it straight
of what our democracy is and what it
isn't yes bobert it's a constitutional
republic and we the people have the
ability to elect our Representatives
into that public Republic
and we have the responsibility as a
citizenry of this country to elect
serious people into those positions to
represent us not [__] fake outrage
machines like me in Congress you do not
want me in Congress you don't want me
and God it's not it's not going to go
well I probably will be science and
censored and probably expelled and
removed
I I definitely do not want Congress I
belong behind this microphone every
single weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific right
here on YouTube Twitter and twitch don't
forget to hit the Subscribe button on
the YouTube channel follow us every
single weekday and download on Apple
Spotify and Google
do us a favor download each one and then
play it in two times the speed for at
least the first 30 minutes it's
hilarious Gabe when you listen to me
like in twice this week yeah it's
[__] hilarious it really is make sure
to follow us on Twitter at Tony Michaels
pod also on Facebook at the Tony
Michaels and make sure to take your
Amazon Prime account over to Twitch link
it together and give us that one free
subscription that you get from your
Amazon Prime account and renew it every
month you have to renew your
subscription every month and we get a
couple bucks
of Amazon's money every single month
it's free for you to do also if you want
to give us monetary support Gabe you can
visit his website what was that show.com
what was that show.com dates you
directly to his patreon page why you're
on patreon visit my patreon page
patreon.com the Tony Michaels also games
is patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez find
all the new extra content over there on
patreon that's one way to give us
monetary support and we appreciate all
the patreon members out there on our
patrons we appreciate you more a new new
episode there was a man I don't know if
I can I'm kicking these episodes out man
I know you're doing them in the car it's
fast I know I know you know the other
day when we were playing the one on the
show there was a guy running I'm like
did you get did you get the the consent
from him to show him yeah there's a
whole thing like whenever you now
there's a part of me where I'm like I
want it like I've got a whole new studio
set up oh against go against go against
the grain of your own instincts and
don't worry about the details for anyone
who doesn't know I do a show called what
was that and I've now positioned myself
inside my car so there's always
something happening in the background
there's someone [__] that's the best
part walking there was a kid the other
day who didn't make it in because the
take was not good but he was he rode by
on his bike on the side and then just
hung out in the back so you could see
him through the back window and then he
just kept going
like waving to me so he knew that you
were recording he knew because I've got
a ring light in my car so that way it
doesn't look so dark in the car oh yeah
well you can see it in your eyes every
once yeah yeah I got these crazy right
mutinizes
so anyway there's a new one I'm gonna be
doing that's on the uh the new Trump
trading cards and I'll probably end up
doing one about Margaret Taylor green
getting [__] pwned in this in this
hearing great so go to patreon.com I am
Gabe Sanchez and patreon.com the Tony
Michaels visit our patreon page there
also it's hat week remember it's hat
week go to the Tony michaels.com click
the Hat Link store you can use the promo
code hat week 10 that's hat week one
ten percent off your hat order Loki I
promise I'm gonna get those uh beanies
up here soon so be paying attention
there I'll announce it while I'm on air
when we got the beanies live but go to
go to d30michaels.com click the hat
store link
and use the promo code hat week 10
that's hat week one zero for ten percent
off your hat order same time
same place tomorrow Surf's Up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon